I don't want to die you can hire the
best doctors I can hire the best
scientists death is the destination we
all share no one has ever escaped it
yeah no no he doesn't want to die is
Jeff Bezos trying to live forever to
write your legacy
what would you want your legacy
to read can you tell me who's the
richest person in the world
Jeff Bezos
do you want to be even richer than him
yes of course
[Music]
we need to do this for the future of our
children the future of our great country
the future of mankind this is your
brother and I've got a very important
message alhamdulillah brother Eddie is
setting up the dean Center not just the
dean show but the dean Center a full
dawa Academy a Masjid a dawa Center in
America the first of its type the a
groundbreaking project and I want
everybody as I'm supporting it I want
everybody to support it so we can take
the dawah to the next level we need the
dean Center please support it
[Music]
foreign
I want to thank you all for hosting us
here at this wonderful community in
Florida Brandon thank you guys later to
be with everybody and we're going to get
right into it as you know we started
back in 2006 one of the first and one of
the only
Islamic TV talk shows that we've been
trying to deliver the purpose of life in
a very simple easy to understand way
without compromising delivering the
message of tohi the pure monotheism and
that's what I want to talk to you about
Cher sure you know recently it was some
sad events that happened here in Florida
you know there was a hurricane heading
towards Tampa wasn't it and I heard it
took a little reverse and it went in
another Direction
and I was talking to a friend of mine
so alhamdulillah this community was kept
safe
and it's sad that many other places they
were they went under so I'm talking to a
friend of mine from Naples
and he's describing to me how on the
beachfront they have homes I'm not
talking about ten thousand dollar homes
or a hundred thousand dollar homes I'm
talking about 10 million dollar homes 20
million dollar homes all the way up to
40 million dollar homes and he said that
all of them
they were close to this area between him
and Fort Myers
gone
so right away I'm thinking like okay
insurance he said no
he said they don't get the flood
insurance because they're right there on
the beach that's what he's telling me
so I started thinking subhanallah
when these things happen you know many
people invest all their money their time
their effort into the Dunya into the
material world calamities like this hit
are these times that Allah says signs
that people reflect are these are times
that people really get to contemplate
and reflect purpose why am I here why
have I been created what are your
thoughts when you hear something like
this
there is a beautiful verse which detects
that in
in a so in a beautiful way and Surat
yunus
uh
in that verse Allah
mentions that Allah brings down rain
then because of the rain you start
having vegetation
and then it grows and the one who placed
the seed and
was the caretaker of this particular
vegetation
uh would look at it in a very uh
boastful
and admiring it Allah
uses a very interesting way
until they became so confident that we
own this this is ours
that's it we control this
they forgot who brought the ring down
they forgot why they are here
Allah
Allah his command
came and he wiped it off
exactly also like the people of the
Guardian
there is a
uh
the three brothers who went to harvest
they had this beautiful garden and they
refused to share with them as a team
so they went to
harvest this Garden in the middle of the
night so that the poor and the needy
would not wake up in the morning and
share with them or come and request
their sheer the sadata from that Harvest
Allah also sent something a stone that
wired it away so again this becomes like
a reminder that you're not in control of
anything you're only here for a test and
Allah
sometimes he tests you with what you
consider to be good and sometimes he
tests you with what you consider to be
well the people of odd he talked about
how they built
they were almost 50 what feet
tall
you know and they built their homes and
the strongest structures they used to
dig their homes in the mountains see how
strong they are
uh
um
[Music]
as foreign
but on Earth and they said who's
stronger than us
who's stronger than us you know look how
Allah
and Allah
don't they reflect and consider there is
someone who created them
shouldn't he be stronger than them who
made you strong Allah who made you
wealthy Allah so he must be stronger
than you and he must be wealthier than
you again how does Allah destroy them
With the Wind with the Wind
[Music]
a storm like this you know sometimes we
belittle the wind that's wind you know
it's nothing but subhanallah Allah
makes the wind out of context out of the
norm and to the extent that it destroys
uh things that we you know are precious
to us there's another individual who
runs one of the most successful
companies name is uh Jeff Bezos you
heard of him what like these are people
who see themselves as Gods who want to
be World historical figures they're
they're literally do that who do you
think is doing that well like like Jeff
Bezos you think he thinks himself as a
God yeah really yeah really you don't
Jim Bezos was Amazon yeah yeah so now uh
you know because these things really
when you have all this type of money
yeah and now as one who has submitted to
the will of the Creator not the creation
of Muslim you're always being reminded
you know because this guy gathered
that's what I was going to ask you next
yeah so the thing is that obviously as
Muslims we're trying to prepare we're
trying to have that wealth in our hands
not in our heart and to remind ourselves
that always being conscious of the
afterlife and trying to plant those
seeds of goodness so then we could be
prepared to go ahead and have what's
waiting for us in the next life but now
when someone like Jess Bezos he starts
to think like hold on all this money
right now I can hire the best doctors I
can hire the best scientists let's talk
about that because that was something
that was recent You Came Upon that he
tried to put a committee together to see
how his life can be what extended yeah
no no he doesn't want to die is Jeff
Bezos trying to live forever far right
your legacy
what would you want your legacy
to read world's oldest man
is but I would love it let's work on
that I keep telling my biotech friends
hurry
to Hell guys come on yeah so he gathered
those I don't know if you guys read this
or not but it shows out their public
record that he gathered some doctors
scientists people in the field of
biology you know okay I don't want to
die death is the destination we all
share no one has ever escaped it and
that is as it should be because death is
very likely the single best invention of
life
it's life's change agent it clears out
the old to make way for the new
find the way that I want to live so I
kind of enjoy this money because of how
you can do that subhanallah you can
regardless of how much you know he's
what's up look at look at us that's the
beauty of believing in the Hereafter you
know you know I you know you always
think of the year after that you're
gonna go out there to Allah
and you're gonna find something bitter
actually bitter then what you had here
even if you had what this his name is
basil Jeff basil basil yeah even if you
have as much as his subhanallah the
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
described the Dunya for the Believers to
be healed
whatever you will have in the Hereafter
even if you have as much as basil you
know the the Hereafter is way bitter yes
Dad can you tell me who's the richest
person in the world
ah
Jeff Bezos
do you want to be even richer than him
yes of course
listen to me carefully Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said the two
sunnarakas of Fajr is better than the
whole world and everything in it
now go pray
[Music]
you know there is
person or Scholars wouldn't recommend me
saying that the poorest person in gender
the poorest the last one would intergen
the last one supposed to be the poorest
he's going to have 10 times this world
the entire world ten times the entire
world you know can you and this is the
last one who will come the last Muslim
who will come out of hell and will be
blessed in general ten times this world
imagine that you were also sharing with
me earlier and authentic Hadith from the
last message sent to mankind Muhammad
peace and blesses be upon them talking
about and differentiate the four the one
who has money doesn't have a mind has
you know can you break that down for us
because of some really powerful to
really have us reflect even more
uh you're referring to uh Hadith ABI
capital and Mary
Hadith is authentic
subhanallah is so beautiful that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
actually asked us to memorize it
very few things the prophet would say
and he would tell you memorize this one
he said what were in me
I'm gonna narrate to you a Hadith I want
you to memorize it look at this
there are four types of people in this
world
you're one of them by the way
you belong to one of them number one the
first
[Music]
the first is someone Allah had given
knowledge to he has knowledge knowledge
of the religion knowledge of the air
Farah knowledge of why he is here
knowledge of why he is being tested the
wisdom behind his test and Allah given
his him money to wealth both he has
wealth and knowledge knowledge is and
wealth because of his knowledge he is
very careful
and how he earns the money and how he
spends it
very careful
on the day of judgment there will be two
questions when it comes to money
the the prophet saw Allah mentioned that
the feet of the son of Adam will not
move
out of that end of gathering unless he
is asked about
there is one word in five one word in
four one of them is about his wealth how
did he earn it
and how did he spend it both
for this man because of his knowledge he
earned the money from he doesn't earn it
from Hawaii
also he utilizes the money yet
[Music]
he spends in the calls of Allah from
this wealth also he uses the 12th to
uphold his kinship ties
that he shares with his closest kids
you know he's not stingy in a way
and this is the best you can be
this is the top of the line that Allah
will give you money and knowledge
look the second one someone Allah
given knowledge but no money
but subhanallah because of that
beautiful knowledge
is not invasive of the first one
you know he understands that wolf is
Father Allah choose him over me
alhamdulillah this is father
but he wishes to be like him
he says if I would have his money I
would do like him
I would swim like him
I would build this Masjid I would build
a school I would help the needy I would
help the poor he's always what work on
his intention wanting to be like the
first one without what without wishing
for him to lose it yeah for there is a
destructive envy and there is
constructive Envy in Arabi the word envy
is not mentioned it's called Ripa
constructive envy that you wish to be
like the other person without wishing or
wanting Allah to take away what they
have that's Ripple that you will be like
the person so this is the second best
look at this the second one because of
his intention
the goal of his intention he equals the
first one so he didn't do any work and
look at the beauty of knowledge when you
have knowledge he didn't do anything he
was not tested with the money he did not
worry about how did he earn it how did
he spend he just had a good intention
because of that intention he will
receive the same reward like the first
one the prophet said
because of his intention he receives an
equal status equal reward like the first
one so those are what
two so what was the first one
knowledge and knowledge and wealth the
second one
knowledge without wealth look at the
third one and the third one Allah
given him Wills no knowledge
[Music]
he doesn't have any knowledge
see see the significance of knowledge
Allah it was a prophet used the term
unbelievable the Arabi brothers would
understand I looked for an English I
look for an English there is nothing
really
have you ever seen someone who's drunk
and he's walking around and he's hitting
everybody
have you ever seen that scene you know
that's how he handles his money
is he not the best but yeah he's he's I
know he doesn't care whether he earns it
from Haram usually he goes and gets used
any money he earns the the Haram money
and then he spends it uh
Allah told us the story
that a very wealthy
Arab okay we're not going to identify
his National here so we don't get in
trouble
uh went to London
very wealthy you know the people with
the Oilers yeah
so he's in a circle waiting there is a
light out there and he was driving this
uh
there's a car called
something like that very and he had a
bag of money with him you know imagine
it so somehow shaytan came and said I
want to see the Brits running after my
money
so you know what he did he he of course
his car has that uh sunroof so he stood
up and he opened the bag of money
and he throwed
look at the bridge they have taken away
look how lovely this is
that Thai imagine someone who who goes
and nearby is Michael Angelo Victor half
a million
this is not even your thing you know or
someone who has a boat
for what
you know or or people who go and buy
these you know for what this is what
messing around with the money and in the
day of judgments subhanallah you're
going to be asked where did we spend
that money
this is the worst look at the last one
the worst of the worst
news
Allah did not give him money no
knowledge nothing
but because he lacked the knowledge so
he wishes to be like who
the first
the second the third you want to be like
the third
I wish I have this money man this guy
this is the and and those who are
mentioned uh these four types were
mentioned in the story of tarun
[Music]
I hope you you're planning to be number
what
one or at least two
but please stay away from three and four
because this is disasters last question
Sheikh I want to go ahead and connect it
with what we started off with given an
example how just in a fraction of a
second everything can go ahead and just
be wiped out all of the Dunya things but
will your investment in the dean in a
Masjid in the dawah does that get wiped
out after leaves you
look at the prophet saw Allah
always says I want the money I want the
money I want the money
what do you then Allah says what what do
you want the money for oh son of Adam
what do you need the money for literally
you need to eat
I'll get hungry again and eat
oh you need to wait
and it gets old and then you wait it
again that's what you need the money for
but look at this one
um
but your true wealth is what will stay
for you on the day of judgment that you
spend in this world
and Allah will give it to you on the day
of judgment
the context is there
when he was given a sheep
and his wife
knew that the prophet salallahu would
like to eat the shoulder
but the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam said to her I want you to
slaughter and please share it with our
leaders he didn't ask him to keep
anything
do you want to verify whether she did
this or not
what happened to The Shield you know
what she said all of it is gone or have
gone I I shared it as period instruction
accept the shoulder you know what the
prophet said
all of it
stayed except the shoulder
so subhanallah when you spin
you know I'm sorry to say that we live
in a country
I mean I'm not this is a disclaimer you
have to pay your Social Security you
know they take a whole bunch of your you
know a whole chunk of money from your
uh paycheck right what's it called
Social Security
I don't make any money so that's why I I
don't see that Social Security right
Social Security when are you supposed to
get that social security
what age 65 now and very soon it's gonna
be 70 right you know what the prophet
said the lifespan of my room between 60
and 70.
the majority of us are going to live
until 60 and hardly till 70. so when are
you gonna get this money
and we believe the system and we take
the money yes I want to imagine Allah
from you and by the way these guys they
invest that money weird our guys here
they invest the money away and
so they infest your Social Security and
work in usury in Bank stuff in mortgage
and all that stuff is Haram stuff and
when they need it they break into it
okay let's take some money from because
we're in debt here you know but look at
in Allah Allah will accept the sadaqa
from you
foreign
exactly like you raise a baby horse
is
for you better than stocks better than
stocks and crypto no of course crypto no
no nothing of that and Allah is not
gonna break into it because he needs it
Allah doesn't need it's going to need
Allah is going to give it to you and
that's that you know just compare this
with that absolutely and again we still
reluctant to spending the calls of Allah
and this is why you know the Hadith of
the whole that I just quoted right now
you know how it started
how tall it the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam said
three things I'm willing to take off on
first of all why rasulullah
needed to take out from this
why the disbelievers themselves
how did they describe them how did they
label him what did they say to him you
are what you know what he saw in that
mountain and he said to them if I tell
you that there is an army behind this
mountain
who's about to attack you will you
believe me what did they say to him
what did they say we will believe you
why
why
we never experienced new lying you
always tell the truth why would we
accuse you of lying now huh rasulullah
is is spoken to Muslims telling them
Allah look at number one
your wealth will never decrease because
of a sadaqah that you give for the sake
of Allah
so your money will not decrease
not only that Allah said in the Quran
that Allah will give it to you
will give it back to you and fact
whatever you spend in the cause of Allah
Allah will give it to you
imagine that your will never decrease
because of asada that you give
so you've been here with us quite a few
times what are your impressions on the
property now that we're looking to take
the d show into the dean Center
um I almost uh I have known it is for
years I think maybe close to 20 years
and you know in the in Chicago we used
to have this you know Studio this nice
humble Studio nothing extravagant
but he would bring us you know to the
studio and and he would talk about the
ideals you know
and I always told him that there is a
difference between talking about it and
actually executing it
so he decided to actually move to the
next level and and try to establish
something Allah has blessed him with a a
nice piece of property some of you may
have seen it whether physically or
virtually
uh where he wanted to have this dawa
sensors
you know and so how about this I think
that it's on Route 60 right 66 or 60
something 16. Highway 60. beautiful
uh imagine having a fine year the dean
Center and the police is welcoming you
know the places will come so that's what
IDI imagine if someone gets guided in
that Center brothers and sisters in
Islam the prophet said this to him
he said
if Allah Guides Through you one soul is
better than the entire world it's been
one Soul now you become a means to that
you help with that Brothers there will
be also a message there a full-time
Masjid five daily prayers inshallah
there is a need for a Masjid in this
area I have not seen one so there is a
need for a Masjid in this area also
we're planning to have a full-time
School
full-time school to educate the next
generation of Muslims and on and on and
on and stood you also to produce
materials for our children so this is a
good investment for us
so we ask Allah to place it in your
heart that you can heal our working hard
day after day to get stuff done we have
actually our architect who came all the
way from Georgia brother Abdul qadir is
right there for the last four days by
the way he's been working and you know
doing the master plan and then we're
going to do the design with brother
Ahmad here from Maryland
mashallah they came to uh because we're
going to talk about the design how are
we going to make that beautiful design
that our Center within and when the
school and so we're going to come up
with a master plan for the whole thing
and we're gonna phase it out in a way
that it can can be affordable inshaallah
but we need your help tonight just to
move on a little bit because what we we
want to make sure that this place is
ready to go by Ramadan isn't that what
you have in mind that's the inshallah
so you know that's what we have you know
this is
a beautiful project I have been involved
personally in many of them but this is
something that is so special for life so
special if one person accepts Islam
because of you because of your effort
it's worth more than hold on yeah this
is your brother from Dallas Texas I'm
here in support of the dean center it's
a beautiful organization Masha Allah in
the U.S and they have purchased a piece
of land and several building on it and
we are counting our brother and sister
throughout the US throughout the world
to be part of this magnificent project
it doesn't matter how much you give it
doesn't matter how much at you donate
what matter we all participate inshallah
may Allah bless you thank you so much
[Music]